물론 두 개의 불연속적인 결과가 나오죠. 이진 결과만 반환하는 디지털 양자 컴퓨터에서 실험을 수행했으니까요.
맞는 말이에요. 하지만 양자 컴퓨터가 이진 결과를 반환하는 이유, 즉 양자 컴퓨팅이 작동하는 이유가
바로 슈테른과 게를라흐가 처음 발견한 이 스핀 양자화 때문이라는 점을 기억해야 해요.
IBM 양자 컴퓨터의 qubit은 스핀을 기반으로 하지 않지만, 다른 많은 양자 컴퓨터는 그래요. 그래서
양자 컴퓨터로 슈테른-게를라흐 실험을 수행하면 스핀 양자화를 실제로 재발견할 수 있어요.
1922년 이후로 원래 슈테른-게를라흐 실험에 대한 수많은 확장 실험들이 수행됐어요. 이 확장 실험들은
동일한 원자 빔을 여러 슈테른-게를라흐 장치에 통과시켜서 다양한 상황에서 스핀이 어떻게 행동하는지 알아봐요.
여기 하나를 소개할게요. 원자 빔을 한 장치에 통과시켜서 스핀 업 빔과 스핀 다운 빔 두 개로 나누고
그 두 빔 각각을 별도의
장치에 통과시켜 볼게요. Qiskit에서 이 실험에 해당하는 quantum circuit은 마지막 것과 비슷하지만
측정이 두 번이에요. 여기서는 오븐의 효과를 모방했던 무작위 회전을
Hadamard라는 gate로 교체했어요. Hadamard를 적용하면 오븐과 동일한 측정 확률이 나오거든요.
하지만 사용하기가 훨씬 간단해요. 그래서 한 번 측정하고 두 번 측정하는데
실험 결과 측정 히스토그램은 이렇게 생겼어요. X축의 비트 문자열은 두 번 측정의
결과에 해당해요. qubit이 두 번 모두 0으로 측정되면 00 비트 문자열에 해당하고, 또는
처음 0 그다음 1로 측정되면 10에 해당하는 식이에요. 첫 번째 실험에서 스핀 업으로 측정되면 두 번째에서도 스핀 업이 될 것 같아요.
스핀 다운 원자도 마찬가지예요. 즉 첫 번째 실험에서는 업이나 다운을 측정할 확률이 같지만, 두 번째 실험에서는 결과가 이미 결정된 거예요.
그래서 두 번째 슈테른-게를라흐 장치 각각의 끝에 있는 두 스크린에는 각각 하나의 점만 있을 거예요.
한 스크린에는 스핀 업 원자가 모두 있고 다른 스크린에는 스핀 다운 원자가 모두 있을 거예요. 다음 실험으로
순수하게 스핀 업 원자 빔으로 시작해 볼게요. 실제 물리적 슈테른-게를라흐 실험에서는 슈테른-게를라흐 장치에 통과시키고
아래로 편향된 빔을 차단함으로써 이걸 할 수 있어요. 그러면 위로 편향된 원자들이 모두
스핀 업이 돼요. 이제 이 빔을 또 다른 슈테른-게를라흐 장치에 통과시키되, 이번에는 자석을 90° 회전시켜서
자기장 기울기가 이쪽으로 이동하는 원자들을 위아래 대신 좌우로 편향시키도록 해요. 하나의 점이 보일까요 두 개의 점이 보일까요 아니면 완전히 다른 게 보일까요? 이 실험을 위해
Qiskit에서 다음 circuit을 실행할 거예요. 이 실험의 원자 빔이 모두 스핀 업이므로 0 상태에서 시작해요.
그런 다음 이 Hadamard gate가 x와 z 좌표를 교환해서
슈테른-게를라흐 장치를 회전시키는 효과를 내요. 이제 위아래 대신 좌우 스핀 투영을 측정하는 거예요.
여기서 이런 모양의 측정 히스토그램을 얻어요. X 방향의 스핀도
두 가지 값만 취할 수 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 스핀 레프트(spin left)와 스핀 라이트(spin right)라고 부를 수 있어요.
그래서 이 실험은 이전에 Z 방향으로 스핀 업으로 측정된 스핀의 X 투영을 측정하면 같은 확률로 스핀 레프트 또는 라이트가 나온다는 걸 보여줘요.
마지막으로 고전적 기대와 대조해서 차이를 정말 명확하게 부각시켜 볼게요.
고전적으로는 작은 원자 막대자석이 장치의 자기장 기울기에 수직으로 가리키면
그 원자에 작용하는 힘이 0이어야 한다고 했던 거 기억하죠. 위아래로 편향되지 않아야 해요. 그 경우 스크린 한가운데에 하나의 점만 보여야 해요.
그런데 두 개의 점이 보여요. 즉 절반의 원자는 스핀 레프트이고 절반은 스핀 라이트예요.
이전에 업으로 측정됐는데도요. 그래서 양자역학적 관점에서 보면, 스핀 업을 위를 가리키는 벡터에,
스핀 다운을 아래를 가리키는 벡터에 대응시키고 싶을 수 있지만, 마지막 실험에서 볼 수 있듯이 그렇게 단순하지 않아요.
여기서 무슨 일이 일어나는지 정말 이해하려면 양자 중첩과 측정이라는 주제를 더 깊이 파고들어야 해요.
이건 다른 날 영상에서 다룰 거예요. 양자역학이 정확히 어떻게 작동하는지에 대한 더 많은 의문이 남은 것처럼
슈테른과 게를라흐도 그랬어요. 그들의 실험이 모든 걸 설명하지는 못했지만
자연 세계를 이해하는 데 양자역학이 필수적이라는 걸 확립하는 데 크게 기여했어요.
그 실험은 양자역학에서 가장 중요한 기초 실험 중 하나였어요. 운동량의 양자화를 증명하고
스핀이라는 자연의 새로운 기본 특성에 대한 증거를 제공했어요. 양자 세계의 법칙을 정말로 이해하고
씨름하기 위해 슈테른과 게를라흐 같은 물리학자들은 직접 손을 더럽혀가며
실험을 설계하고, 예측을 세우고, 때로는 틀리기도 했어요. 직접 해보는 것을 대체할 건 정말 없어요.
그러니 실제 양자 실험을 직접 해보고 싶다면 슈테른-게를라흐 모듈로 가보세요.
설명란에 링크가 있어요. 시청해 주셔서 감사하고 다음에 또 봬요.
정말 실제 양자 실험을 해보고 싶다면 설명란에 링크된 슈테른-게를라흐 모듈로 가보세요.